let's talk about how to cure toenail
fungus for under two bucks all right so
what is this fungus fungus kind of is in
the family of fungus yeast
mold
and these microorganisms love a warm
moist environment like in your shoes
this specific fungus is called
dermatophyte if you want to know that
now i just want to say that
you have
friendly fungus beneficial fungus called
symbiotic fungus and you have pathogenic
or unfriendly fungus and yeast and mold
and things like that
in fact i want to show you something
in this book that i'm reading which is
actually quite
fascinating it's called mycorrhizal
planet how symbiotic fungi work with
roots to support plant health and build
soil fertility
now check this out
pick a handful of old growth forest soil
and you'll be holding
26 miles
of linear
mycelium now what is mycelium mycelium
is this fungus in the superficial layer
of the earth it's just a very friendly
fungus that does a lot for the plant and
the soil so in just one handful of
dirt in the forest you have 26 miles of
these little thread-like fungus
that are helping breaking down leaves
they're helping decompose different
things into smaller particles they
actually act as another organ for the
plant to help break down minerals and
help feed the roots in exchange the
plant gives them carbohydrates okay as
an exchange so give me the carbs i'll
give you the minerals so we have all
these microorganisms living all around
us but this specific microbe is not the
friendliest and it's an overgrowth of a
certain fungus that normally should be
in check by our own immune system but it
can get out of control
now here's the challenge that i see here
when you take medication and again i'm
not telling you not to take medication
i'm just giving you the data
lamisol
lamisol that's a common medication they
use for toenail fungus you're going to
take it orally
and you're usually going to take it for
two to three months okay
now the problem is
this medication penetrating all the way
deep into the inside of your nail i mean
you have to take it a long time to
penetrate but in the meantime it's doing
a number on your liver
some of the side effects it can increase
liver enzymes it can cause liver damage
it can cause
lupus okay which is an autoimmune
disease it can create central nervous
system damage it can actually put you in
the motion of depression
and cause a loss of taste and jaundice
which is a liver problem and even
alopecia which is hair loss so not only
does it come with a negative
package with all these side effects but
it's marginally successful it's like 30
to 40
successful now if you look up
alternatives to this like natural
remedies there's going to be a lot of
stuff you're going to read that oh
there's not any studies that shows that
it works
or it could be harmful or this and that
but i want to give you some solutions
that i've personally seen do work so
these solutions i'm going to talk about
at least have
less side effects a lot less side
effects if any and they potentially
could actually really help you get rid
of this nasty fungus now i've done a
video on this before where i talked
about soaking your feet in epsom salts
which is magnesium sulfate for about 15
minutes a day and then drying your feet
out and making sure that you're maybe
wearing sandals around the house so your
feet aren't so sweaty and you're gonna
be adding two teaspoons of epsom salts
and four cups of water and you're gonna
heat it up so it's nice and dissolved
and you're just gonna soak your feet in
there okay so this is a good remedy the
problem with this remedy is it does take
a long time to work you're doing this
for weeks and weeks and weeks okay so
i'm going to give you a couple other
things that are a little bit faster okay
tea tree oil
it originates in australia it's been
used by the indigenous australians for a
very long time and they used it for
coughing
acne
dandruff
all topically they don't take it orally
as well as lice scabies and fungus it's
a natural wide spectrum anti-fungal
compound it inhibits fungal mycelium and
this is that fungus i talked about i
mean the interesting thing about a lot
of these natural remedies like even tea
tree oil it's developed these unique
protective mechanisms against
environmental pathogens which are
funguses it could be viruses and
bacteria and so we can tap into that and
use that to help our own bodies because
it's natural and it's going to have a
lot less side effects now there is
another remedy that i'm going to
recommend that's even less expensive
than tea tree oil
and it's under two dollars
simple iodine okay just one drop of this
iodine on the toenail fungus every
single day will inactivate that fungus
to the point where it's not going to be
there anymore now there's a couple
things about it some people don't like
this bright yellow color that it's going
to do on your nail well guess what you
can get decolorized iodine okay and that
way it's clear it's not going to be a
problem or if you don't mind the color
stain i would recommend povidone type
iodine it's very inexpensive and it's
pretty non-toxic i did a video on how to
get rid of skin tags with this iodine
and all you need is one drop of this
every single day on the toenail put it
topically
try to keep your feet dry
okay not in a moist environment
especially around the house
let your feet breathe and make an
environment where the fungus cannot grow
now there's one very very important
point i want to mention and that has to
do with what
fungus live on they live on
carbohydrates okay they're not keto
friendly they're carb junkies so guess
what if you start consuming less
carbohydrates the risk of this coming
back are going to drop down dramatically
if you want more information about that
i put the video that you need to watch
first
right here